on est toujours pressé ça nous fasse
aider tant de mal à la vie à une capsule
de la machine cvt
moi je les mets dans les sec et j'ai
réussi classes chez moi et après on sait
pas ce qui se passe
mission de la table de tri le turbo se
faire peur ce qui fait en sorte que vos
c'est paris le colis qui contenait donc
le marc de café va tomber en dessous et
la capsule d'aluminium après ça est fait
battre vos conduits sont dans la machine
la compagnie de m ressources a une
longue expérience du recyclage des
contenants et de leurs contenus on en
est venu à est en mesure de trouver une
machine est de trouver des marchés pour
chaque matière
puis depuis le début tout ce qu'on voit
de mois en mois de semaine en semaine
c'est une évolution la constance il y a
trois ans l'expression a approché
l'entreprise de saint jean sur richelieu
pour développer un procédé visant à
traiter les capsules le plastique
l'aluminium et le marc de café l'anarcho
alors pour chaque ferme avec les sacs
verts déposés dans les bacs de recyclage
qui arrive directement des centres de
tri et les sacs rouges déposé dans les
boîtes aux lettres
c'est environ 100 tonnes par mois de
capsules nespresso qui sont traités ici
au début on faisait seulement le québec
quand la suède avec canada parce qu'il
rend après dans le décor d'un non lieu
ont commencé à prendre l'eau de notre
point de vue les dosettes
c'est pas la solution pour l'organisme
équiterre tout cela c'est du marketing
pour un produits suremballés en fait des
efforts aujourd'hui pour solutionner un
problème qu'on a créé mais ça a suscité
la grogne des citoyens alors les
entreprises s être une solution
et il ya le transport léger us est ce
que le café va se rendre dans le
compostage dans le bondage et aucune
perte
autant l'emballage de classiques et le
dépit et vitupérer et qui peut être
conditionnel est finie les lumières me
suis allé récupérer au complet le marc
de café con argot compose pour faire
d'épandage agricole
nous ne sommes plus à l'ère des
traitements des déchets nous sommes à
l'ère des prévention des déchets mais
c'est sûr qu'on y pense c'est ce qu'on y
pense le l'environnement est tout seul
on essaie de fa note par les recycler le
caractère recyclable du produit est
devenu une condition pour les
consommateurs qui veulent s'assurer que
leur café du matin n'est pas une menace
la planète ici à nourrice des papiers
radio canada montréal